die frage ist jetzt was und welche
konsequenzen zieht die afg aus diesem
wahlergebnis und zu diesen fragen hatte
ich vor wenigen minuten gelegenheit mit
den parteivorsitzenden und
spitzenkandidaten der partei für die
bundestagswahl mit timo grub aller hier
zu sprechen
europa ist hat sich jetzt dass die
prognose von gestern abend bestätigt
10,3 das kann sie ja eigentlich nicht
zufrieden stellen sie waren darauf aus
wesentlich mehr bei der bundestagswahl
an wählern wählerinnen für die kfd zu
begeistern ist dass ihre verantwortung
als spitzenkandidat geht das mit ihnen
nach hause also insgesamt bin ich doch
zufrieden natürlich hätte ich mir ein
zwei prozent mehr gewünscht ist ganz
klar aber wäre natürlich mit den freien
wählern in eine partei die natürlich
auch in unseren reihen doch abgesagt hat
genauso viel vielleicht sogar die basis
was die krone kritik angeht wir haben
uns stabilisiert wir sind noch dazu mit
dem medialen gegenwind doch mit einem
sehr starken ergebnis in den bundestag
wieder gekommen und ich denke wir haben
schon auf die richtigen themen gesetzt
was sie jetzt absagen nennen nennen ja
die wahl falsche wählerwanderung und wie
ist ziemlich eindeutig sie verlieren an
alle parteien bis auf einen an die spd
sogar 220.000 wähler die haben sie
früher mal von der spd geholt nur bei
der linkspartei können sie nennen es
wird gewinnen sie verlieren auch an die
nichtwähler an die nichtwähler partei
was sagen sie denn zu dieser tatsache
dass sie sagen jetzt freie wähler die
würden hätten das
kfd sozusagen wieder abgezogen in
wirklichkeit haben in ihr ganz andere
parteien die wähler abgezogen die
parteien von denen sie früher so viel
gewonnen haben ja wir müssen jetzt immer
insgesamt natürlich schauen hier ging es
in einen wahlkampf hauptsächlich nur um
personen und das hat sich natürlich auch
gezeigt dass er sicherlich auch wähler
an die spd verloren aber insgesamt hat
sich dieser wahlkampf ja kaum auf themen
auf inhalte ausgezahlt und die das thema
was die medien auch nur hochgespielt mit
den grünen zusammen das klima thema war
ihm nicht für die weder das hauptthema
also ich denke wir haben schon um gerade
in den neuen ländern auf die richtigen
themen auf die sozialen themen gesetzt
deswegen auch der zuwachs von den linken
und wir müssen sich denke ich in der
breite natürlich mehrere themen
ansprechen wir brauchen die vision als
afd das will ich gar nicht verhehlen
dass wir da auch natürlich besser werden
müssen gut sie sagen das klima wenn ich
so ein wichtiges thema gewesen das war
auf platz zwei der wichtigsten themen in
ganz deutschland gewesen sie sagen jetzt
hat er sich zu sehr auf personen
konzentriert dieser wahlkampf heißt das
dass die afg dann das falsche
spitzenkandidaten büro hat denn da gibt
es ja auch eine person denn wenn sie uns
mal anschauen lieber in mittelsachsen
und auch in sachsen insgesamt
abgeschlossen am ende in
mitteldeutschland abgeschlossen haben da
kann man ja nicht davon sprechen dass
falsche personal gewählt wurden haben in
sachsen ganz klar gewonnen wo ich
spitzenkandidat war wir haben klar
zugelegt vielleicht hätten wir die
personen all dies weiteren kinogruppe in
diesem wahlkampf mehr nach vorne stellen
sollen wir haben mehr auf themen gesetzt
was richtig war aber insgesamt denke ich
mir hätten wir mehr auf personen
aussetzen müssen 24 prozent in sachsen 4
und 24 prozent in thüringen das in der
tat sind stärkste partei geworden heisst
das jetzt auch dass die afg
mittelfristig zu einer regionalpartei
ost wird beispiel sich nimmt an der csu
die in bayern ja lange erfolgreich war
sich sozusagen vom westen verabschiedet
nein ich denke wir haben regionale
unterschiede bei allen parteien das
müssen wir einfach mal anerkennen und
auch analysieren so wir haben inzwischen
bei der cdu es ist ein nord-süd-gefälle
bei der asg cfd ist es eben ein ost west
gefälle das ist einfach ein stück weit
unser prägenden punkte die wir in
sachsen natürlich hervorbringt die
sozialen themen wie schon angesprochen
habe die geben wir wirklich auf die
probleme und sorgen der menschen ein und
wir müssen im westen vor einigen im
ländlichen raum wesentlich mehr punkten
und dann müssen wir jetzt ansetzen das
heißt also die afg als partei des
ländlichen raums auch als nach wie vor
als sammelbecken für protest für
unzufriedene das schicksal der partei
die linke die ihr lange diese funktion
hatte jetzt die nur wegen dieser
sogenannten grundmandat klaus will noch
in den bundestag kommt weiß ich mehr als
zwei direktmandate gewonnen hat schlägt
sie die nicht wenn sie sich
ausschließlich auf diese
wählergruppierungen konzentrieren also
erstmal muss man sagen wir haben hier
nicht nur protestwähler angesprochen und
selbst der protest ist natürlich wichtig
das gehört zu einer demokratie dazu dass
es auch parteien natürlich mit vertreten
auf der anderen seite haben wir die
stammwählerschaft doch mobilisiert das
ist wichtig wir sind über ein starkes
zehn prozent ergebnis darüber hinaus
gekommen das will ich erstmal sehr
positiv und die linke ja die linke hat
richtig erwischt hat nur auf klima
gesetzt und nicht auf die sozialen
bereich auf die sozialen themen und wir
brauchen ein breites portfolio die
probleme weil wenn ich sehe was corona
angeht was die korona maßnahmen angeht
was die arbeitslosigkeit angeht aber
auch was die rente angeht die liegen
quasi auf der straße und die müssen wir
natürlich stärker inhaltlich bespielen
ein für sie auch unangenehmes ergebnis
der bundestagswahl ist sie verlieren
jetzt alle höchstwahrscheinlich ihren
nimbus und status als stärkste
oppositionsfraktion das ist ja mit
privilegien verbunden ankleiden gleich
auf die regierung oder bisher auf die
kanzlerin antworten das ist jetzt nicht
mehr möglich kompensieren sie das mit
noch schneidigen noch schärfer auftreten
im bundestag in der kommenden
legislaturperiode
ich denke wir kompensieren das damit
dass wir wie einzig wahrnehmbare
opposition bleiben werden und das ist
für mich der positive aspekt denn die
anderen parteien unterscheiden sich auch
programmatisch kommen und das hat ja
auch dieser wahlkampf wenn man das mal
insgesamt analysiert sieht es hat keine
parteien über 30 prozent also wo sind
denn die streiken volksparteien
sozusagen geworden wir haben kaum noch
wähler bindungen und milieus die fest
verankert sind wie die letzten zehn
zwanzig jahre das hat sich aufgelöst und
deswegen sage ich mal für mich sind
nicht bloß wähler der cdu interessant
ich nehme wir da von allen parteien und
für die machen wir auch politik wir
wollen für alle politik machen in der
jüngsten ausgabe des spiegels wird ihnen
ein fremming zugeschrieben die fdp
befindet sich im dritten schleudergang
nach bernd lucke und frauke petry fliegt
jetzt irgendwann auch jörg mayr aus ihr
co parteivorsitzender
wie sehen sie denn die politischen
überlebens chancen von migranten auf dem
parteitag in wiesbaden den sie mitte
dezember veranstalten wir wissen sie
dass in ihm ein fremming das ist
natürlich eine unterstellung des
spiegels was ich so nie gesagt habe wir
werden abwarten was jetzt am im dezember
passiert haben es erst mal die
konstituierung der fraktion und dann
schauen wir uns in parteitag an und das
hat nichts zu entscheiden das haben
immer noch die mitglieder der souverän
unserer partei zu entscheiden dann wird
man sehen wie die personaldebatte dort
weitergeht die frage war ja das
schicksal ihres co vorsitzenden jürgen
halten jetzt kann ich nicht beantworten
ich weiß ja nicht mal antreten möchte
hat dazu hat er sich noch nicht geäußert
also es muss man abwarten
die nekropole im phoenix interview danke
dass sie daran